before we switch over apparently kamala
harris
has just been announced as biden's
vice president thoughts well i i
predicted that one
yep um yeah this is so here's the thing
this
matters a ton because if you so i
i predict there are people he could have
picked
absent unity 2020 happening there are
people he could have picked
that maybe i could have become convinced
that because he cannot possibly last
four years
he was he was the right guy oh yeah if
if he had picked she's
the opposite of that if he had picked
andrew yang or tulsi gabbard my
thought would have been well they're
going to end up in the presidency
probably within the first year even
elizabeth warren frankly who i used to
like a lot and like a lot less now that
she's gone
a bit woke but uh kamala harris
disaster um but you know look this is
just proof of the entire model's
accuracy which is
the dnc is the captor
of the democratic party it is about
influence peddling it
this is to the extent that we have an
obviously
declining uh and mentally
compromised person running at the top of
the ticket
um it is not revealing that it is aware
of that it is going to put someone else
in the secondary position so that
it doesn't miss a beat with respect to
the policy proposals that
it finds preferable
and you know we have no choice but to
revolt against this
the dnc is not your friend